marvel studios just released a brand new
trailer for their upcoming series moon
night and it had a crazy scene included
where mark spector or moon knight is
absolutely beating the daylights out of
what appears to be a non-human character
so the question is who is this non-human
punching bag
welcome back to streaming the galaxy i'm
rocket riley and the new trailer for
moon knight probably gave everyone more
questions than answers but the biggest
question people seem to have is who is
moon knight absolutely thrashing in the
bathroom the series will follow mark
spector the fist of konshu which is a
deity worshiped by ancient egyptians as
the god of the moon in the comics and
seemingly in the trailer spectre has
dissociative identity disorder and
assumes a handful of different
identities to fight crime
this deity khonshu takes advantage of
mark's weakened mental state in order to
control him and make him the fist of
konshu it is in this possession of sorts
where mark specter becomes moon knight
and apparently knocks out monsters and
bathrooms upon first look i actually
thought he was beating up one of the
demogorgons from stranger things after
watching it in slow motion though i
noticed that the character seems to have
somewhat reptilian and dog-like features
so it's most likely the ancient egyptian
god anubis or one of his henchmen since
this series is expected to dive head
first into egyptian mythology it's only
natural that an egyptian deity such as
anubis might show up anubis is
recognized as the egyptian god of the
dead and he actually appeared in the
marvel comics at one point in the comic
mark spectre is killed and enters the
afterlife where he sees anubis while
it's not very likely that mark would be
able to beat up a god let alone on earth
in a bathroom he could be attacking
either a henchman of anubis or someone
else possessed by the spirit of anubis
similar to how mark is somewhat
possessed by the spirit of konshu we've
seen evidence of henchmen of anubis
fighting mark in the comics so i'm
thinking this is probably the most
likely of the two the only other
character this figure could be is
potentially jack russell otherwise known
as werewolf by night a character who was
frequently involved in the moon knight
comic storylines if werewolf by knight
does appear in the series he'll be
played by gail garcia bernal who has
been confirmed to play the character in
a halloween themed special on disney
plus later this year since he's already
confirmed to appear in an upcoming
marvel title it would only make sense
that werewolf by night might appear in
moon knight i'm not completely convinced
though that this figure is a werewolf i
think it's still most likely a henchman
of anubis because it's been rumored for
a while now that other ancient egyptian
deities would be showing up in the show
and anubis is one of the most well known
of them all regardless of who or what
this figure is i think we can all agree
that this series is going to take us in
a completely new and exciting direction
for the marvel cinematic universe
similar to how each of the marvel
television series have done previously
for more marvel television content check
out this video also don't forget to
subscribe like this video and thanks for
watching